that was great it's a it's a real
pleasure to meet you well it's a
pleasure to meet you i've been i i feel
uh like i know you because i really
enjoy your show so much oh thank you
very much
i love you and the everything that's
going on especially that band there
you've got it yeah we have a great band
no i am blessed i'm a blessed man you
really are it's really good it's a nice
warm set i love it yeah i know we're
we're having a good time good and uh
you're having a good time yourself
actually lately you've had uh an
incredible uh you know rising popularity
and you're you're being played on
alternative radio stations uh you've
been on mtv uh what's going on
i'd like to know it's a new vein but i'm
not knocking it it's fantastic you know
all the young adults in america have uh
can they consider me cool
that's great now do you see them
when you do concerts now
thank you very much you know when you do
concerts now today
it's really unbelievable that because uh
i when this happened the first time i
met i was like the uh
the madonna and the michael jackson of
my day you know
and but it was all so new to me i was
very nervous but now the second time
around just being
a trooper and traveling so many years
doing it 45 years to have this happen
with the young adults
is fantastic because i really know what
to leave out now and what to put in and
i'm having more fun with it we're doing
all these rock christmas shows all over
the country in washington and
san francisco and los angeles and uh
dallas you know and and uh have you been
changing what you're doing are you just
doing the same thing i've been doing
this two years
i just uh i go straight ahead with my
great trio ralph sharon's been with me
25 years now mm-hmm
and uh we just play acoustical and it it
works for some reason there's just a
change happening with the young people
that starting to accept all kinds of
music now oh it's great it is uh and uh
i was gonna ask something you did uh uh
an album uh i guess a few years ago
where you recorded all of uh frank
sinatra's yes music we won the grammy
for that perfectly frank it's called
right now
what's your relationship with frank
sinatra do you think that he's ever you
know you disappointed that he's not
recorded an album of your music or do
you think that's well he did it
he did yeah he did uh when he recorded
with i was the first guy to sing with
count basie's band
and the first vocalist uh white vocalist
and uh so then he did an album with uh
basie at the sands hotel years ago with
quincy jones being the producer
and he did all most of the songs that
were very current at the time and there
was the good life and i want to be
around and for once in my life all these
different songs that i introduced
originally
so he did many of my songs what's your
relationship with
big crooners from that era and uh yeah
he's 10 years my elder you know but he i
when i was a real young kid i went to
him for advice at the paramount theater
when he was there with tommy dorsey and
he gave me uh some great advice that
i've i've stuck to
and insisted on it's really helped me
survive because he he said just stay
with great songs many years later just
as recent as last year i said why do you
think we've been around so long he said
because we stayed with great songs
that's terrific i was really hoping it
was advice i could use
but i don't sing
you know what you have is a great sense
of humor a good brain you see and that
that's that pays off in the long run the
cream goes to the top believe me oh
that's nice of you to say i've got this
incredible pompadour
i think that's what it is
you